feels so good i just can't feel
vibrationally like high right now this
is fantastic
likewise the little clicking came back
but we'll see if that persists
in the audio yeah i don't know it's
pretty
yeah it's not too we'll see if it pushed
us
we'll see we we did a
episode with also gina and hillary at
the shift into permanent alignment
retreat as well
and so we just did a little episode of
gilad a moment ago and so now we're all
having a four legs to the chair
conversation right now
so boom we're on
nice we were talking about hillary's
quote
on the previous episode around how
people feel on our nervous system
and like people with much more
egoic separation based finite based
time-based matrix based
trying to extract happiness from
experiences and from other people
and relationships and substances versus
people that basically live
in satchitananda existence consciousness
bliss
that are of a higher vibration
consciousness-wise because they know
their true nature
and how those two feel completely
differently
on the nervous system
yeah that's totally true
yeah i definitely resonate and do you
all think
it's like a personal thing or do you
think it's more of like just a resonance
of your vibration
being able to tell like because some
people
even the people that i feel are still in
the matrix
right can feel okay on my nervous system
but i
at the same time i just think it's a
totally different
feeling when you can just resonate on
another
vibrational level um but i don't know if
you think it's like personal or if you
think it's really the density thing
that's a curiosity for me
i think you can see people's bubbles
of limiting beliefs etc that can feel
but i wanted to bring this up with you
all because it's been something that's
been reflected
to me is the tension
that you feel can feel when
you interact with people that are more
in in the matrix or like have
have these bubbles that are we all have
something but
what's the nature of the tension that
arises when
you interact with these people
and i was thinking about it and
it kind of felt like a frustration of
like oh you're not there
yet you know you're not you're not as
you know
you're in you're in 3d um
and it kind of felt like
a subtle victimization state of
feeling like their bubble
was somehow influencing me in a way
that felt
like maybe i couldn't do anything about
it or does that make sense
like i was just thinking about it
earlier but
i'd love to hear your thoughts on on
that
i love that it's really it's really
solid way to put it
curious curious if other people have a
thought first
this contest this contest that can be
experienced between
states of mind or densities of
consciousness
or in in neurology like being in the
metrics
going back and forth you know between
these
people over three states
which is like in charge so to speak
again
versus like the entitled and
bound by conditions and
carried away state of mind
so that what came up is like the
question
me
can you fall out of this love
you know so then like it's it's a way
for me to see it
even though i was i am and i
am in this entanglement i am like a
weird state
of mind behavior
that's still like i can quantum leap
into
non-judgment like absolute non-judgment
and absolute openness
and absolute understanding and absolute
forgiveness you know all of that and and
for me this is
one that one aspect of the heart of the
the heart of the practice
the heart of the understanding
also
because that's loyal to yourself and not
to
appear
as i see it
yeah absolutely i wish that your
connection was better but yes i think
i got the essence of that
alice i like your amused face
[Laughter]
just laugh and happiness oh
so good
oh wow this is what we're talking about
this is exactly what we're talking about
in its most pure nature
we're just talking about this feeling of
peace
and joy that's it
the nature
is peace and joy that's the
undercurrent as intelligent infinity
yet it remains for you to
recognize that that is your natural
undercurrent because your mind
is toiling you around
nonstop non-stop
and so it took me you know five
plus years of persistently
trying to recognize this
pure joy and peace that is the
undercurrent
such an ananda existence consciousness
bliss truth consciousness bliss
and that this is all that we're talking
about regarding
feeling on the nervous system is that
when people are radiating
peace and joy like the sun
that the vibe is like
[Music]
and then when you have uh when you have
a very
like matrixy egoic separation
vibe it it it's like
it's like when it contrasts that warm
warm it goes
[Laughter]
the sound effects are more than on point
it's
quite amazing actually the sound effects
really
add to the clarity
of that yeah
absolutely and it feels like
it's just much easier to rest
in the natural state with you all
versus going out and
yeah interacting with others that
may be more yeah have more of those
bubbles
and yeah there's a
effortlessness about it effortless
ease yeah
i think it's that recognition as well
yeah like a soul
[Music]
yeah it feels good to be around clearer
mirrors
and you see more of your natural self
or your true self and there's that
recognition and it feels good
to see that
i think that is one of the greatest
challenges that i've faced since
returning
back to home is just
recognizing that i am surrounded by
maybe
unclear mirrors and also not judging
myself
not judging them knowing honoring their
journey
honoring exactly i know that they are
where they are meant to be
just as i am as well and
i i resonate and understand what you're
saying with
feeling um somewhat kind of pulled
energetically when you're in
those energies and i have to like
imagine like there's a white protective
light
like around me a lot of the time and
just kind of
put that into creation because i don't
want to
negatively affect them or vice versa be
you know
i want to be that light be that energy
let that energy speak for itself
but then when you get out of your own
element in that way whereas i feel like
that's what you're saying is you're
being pulled energetically both ways
it doesn't serve you and it definitely
doesn't serve
the other energies that you're around
either but i
as well struggle with that because i
felt that in the last few days you all
like whoa
by the way isn't that contrast exactly
what makes our realization our shift
into
permanent alignment all that more clear
yeah
absolutely yeah the contrast
and i love it all it's just like i want
to kiss their faces i'm so grateful for
the contrast
you know
i was telling gilad that i i reneged on
all of my 2021 commitments i turned in
equity on projects i
wisely distanced myself from people who
i thought
were already quite
you know fairly had some fairly decent
fourth density vibes but that we're
still
nowhere near the level of mastery that
we experienced together three weeks ago
and because of that
that shift into permanent alignment
meant i will no longer architect
i will no longer design i will no longer
build companies i will no longer
work with people that are not
at a level of recognizing themselves as
the creator as recognizing
what the true nature of intelligent
infinity endlessly expressing itself as
these creations
is and if they haven't firmly grounded
themselves in
sachin ananda in the impersonal
awareness
consciousness bliss that fat fundamental
truth
then i can't architect with them
i can serve them but i will not
architect with them so
we're focusing on like the third density
to fourth density
jump right to trampoline people
up into love consciousness into unity
consciousness into god consciousness
into
recognizing more of their true nature
but cosmic consciousness but in order to
efficiently make the protocols that
trampoline people up
we can't build with people that are not
gnostic beings that don't know their
true nature so that's how
i felt and what i was talking to gilad
about in the last
conversation and it was it's a lot of uh
it's a big
sort of starts can be a little bit
tough to to for people to do to you know
re-nag on their on their commitments
because it's no longer their
highest excitement
yeah but do it
if you have to renege to
you know to to take yourself up from the
breadcrumb trail
and to look up and to be like where's
the
the proper next you know yeah on the
trail
and because you to you know to really
work on that
on that highest excitement perpetually
without
just saying oh i already made
commitments
even though i've already shifted into a
different con
level of consciousness but i need to
hold my commitments it's like no
you don't use your will
aligned with god love light highest
wisely gracefully renege
and then move forward architecting only
with those that you feel at the absolute
highest vibration
lined with on your nervous system warm
warm
wow yeah yeah a lot of the time we start
things and we have an expectation that
they're gonna go on for years or like
certain projects or
relationships even friendships whatever
and yeah then you quantum leap and then
you realize they're no longer resonating
with you and they're not of your highest
excitement
and then you're faced a lot of the time
with those lack beliefs of
oh can i let this go what's gonna fill
its place or
you know the reflections that come up
with that
so yeah cool cool for you to just
be able to release that very
easily right
but that [ __ ] was [ __ ] was not easily
but yeah
yeah there was a lot of you know right
now um
like there's almost uh
and you guys know this because we spent
a lot of time in this
state which we can say is that
just peace and joy
just that
we spent a lot of time together in just
that state and so when you in a sense
know this state
you can't you can't
vibe on an architecting level
now in a one-on-one conversation with
somebody on
helping them recognize their true nature
it's totally fair to be able to do that
with them
but on a full-time dedicated
daily business operations
you know global enlightenment style
project it won't it won't work in the
long term because like gina was also
pointing to is that you
you need more than anything to
have your energy aligned
around you on a daily basis in order for
you to be able to abide in order for you
to be able to
recognize your true nature repeatedly
versus get drawn
out into the stickiness that's not your
true nature
silence is one of those things that
is very underappreciated in
the common matrix
world
and i get it because it you can be
uncomfortable
when you're not abiding in that state
where it's just
we're feeling the silences bliss
but
i've i've had yeah i remember states
like
silence was
silence was just so
stimulating like because your mind is
just going crazy with all kinds of
thoughts and feelings
yeah silence oh god i'm like
right now this is so beautiful
i agree i feel like it it used to just
be like deafening
in a way and then i realized why do i
feel the need to fill that space
and then i like jumped out of that aware
or that like
the forest i was in and like was
overseeing it
and i was like no you don't have to fill
that space actually your energy is just
present alone
and just like synergizing with each
other
and it shifts everything
um
something came up can you hear me can
you hear me well
yes so something
before
again about the position of the wise or
the wise one
which which is the hello and
inseparable from also
alignment and harmonization
and evolution of the mind
so it's a it's a saying by ra
whoever maybe not familiar from the raw
material the law of one
channel material um
[Music]
so i says whatever assaults your senses
is catalyst
whatever sorts your senses whatever
assaults
assaults i thought oh assaults
your senses as a catalyst whatever
senses is catalyst yeah
love it and this five words
are so profound because yes it sends all
the way
both into realization of
independence assess efficiency and to a
harmonization
of of your self of your beliefs of your
eyes and so forth so so also in regards
when like seeing
people you know from the matrix and
or like lower vibration so then
if it bothers me if i feel
we're just doing it i'm not sensing okay
the
to this hyper awareness but if it
bothers me if it assaults
my senses somehow my emotional body my
some some sense of like
not not not comfortable or
painful no something like this so it's
kind of list which means it's a
generated
experience for the sake of learning for
the sake
for the sake of balancing for the sake
of seeing something which hasn't been
seen fully
before and to be more responsible being
a master of vibration of mind of
this complex and all is well you know
it's like oh nice
i'm assaulted by this these beings who
are very vulgar and
lack awareness and personal vibration
or whatever and i believe it to be the
case that
my vibration is now lowered and and all
of that
oh beautiful i can forgive
all of that but that there and see like
what is the what is the catalyst what is
the
expensive position that i can
tell now it's
apparent contraction
and with this process also like from
what i
i've seen and less and less even if it's
in this contrast it
less and less it bothers you it's like
it's it's appearing but it's not
it's not sticking it's not sticking to
to the state of being it's like
more and more passing through and not
like staying and sticking and defining
things to be something
yeah so that was the
later input of that the cloud
arises and passes more smoothly and
doesn't
stick yeah yeah
sometimes the cloud will arise for those
that are less trained
adept and it will create a five-hour
long thunderstorm
[Music]
yeah yeah thank you for sharing that go
on
and also you notice when the clouds come
you're saying oh i'm choosing this i'm
creating this
and that is a very empowering
stance to take on it versus why is this
cloud here
getting very wrapped up in
in that yeah i'm the creator of the
experiences versus i'm the
slave the victim
the victim what is this child trying to
teach me versus why is this cloud
happening to me
shifts everything
yeah seeing everything as the catalyst
so sometimes it's not just what's
assaulting our senses but it's also
just what is appearing
itself so just appearances
themselves are wait for us to remember
our true nature repeatedly
i can simply even go as far as to say
that this
sip of water right now
it can be done without
any conscious love or it can be done
with
unbelievable waterfalls oceans of
love for gratitude for the hydrological
cycle on the planet that sustains
this vehicle as it's here as an
apparatus
of intelligent infinity
so there this is like yeah cheers to
agua
gilad where's your water
wow i really love that everything is a
catalyst
mostly assaults
are going to be the largest like is
quoted from the
law of one but yet even something that
is not as an assault
can also be a catalyst for a deeper love
of oneself as the creator for a deeper
love of oneself as intelligent infinity
there's something to learn from every
experience or movie frame
everything that comes up in our reality
was brought for a reason
and like we attracted that into our
reality to learn from it
and the contrast it really does serve it
all serves i mean
how boring would it be if you just like
knew all these things you had to learn
them through contrast and constantly
forgetting and remembering and
it just becomes more clear every time
right like the clarity the questions
create the clarity
you need those questions that contrast
those constant reminders
have you all experienced any sorry go
for it
i was just saying your reality is just a
direct representation
of the things that are coming up for a
reason that you have to learn from and
work
through and then it's a beautiful
mirroring reflection
of your internal world and that's always
a challenge for me too
i'm like but how did i create this and
then i'm like oh
okay that's why it was a little
distortion
[Music]
go ahead gina what were you saying
i was asking if you all have
any catalysts that you've experienced
recently
that you'd want to share about
the one that we spent the first part of
the convo on was
[ __ ] insane like just going
back into away from the container of
like
people that recognize themselves as the
creator and people that
are just bathing in the subtlety of
peace and joy
versus those that are in thunderstorms
non-stop thunderstorms and like seeing
that contrast
really it almost felt like it was the
first time in my life
i had seen the difference between
oh versus
and like that's what it felt like it was
that intense and so it was it was
it was a remember the stickiness of
that matrix the environment and
remember to abide and remember to renege
on the things that no longer
feel like they're the shift into the
highest alignment
and like so that was a huge yeah
huge huge catalyst that's a good
question what about you guys
so what came up before
you say it also now
[Music]
if this seem like okay it's out there
the stickiness
and there's none of that
but then again it's what's out there
[Music]
where's the out there it's here
here it's here it says within myself
i mean okay
so see
six
you're cutting out a little bit repeat
that sentence
yeah so can you hear me now yeah repeat
that sentence
[Music]
yeah yeah i think if you repeat your
sentence we can hear you let's try again
yeah that's right
my money first and
they're in acceptable for me so
i see i still have this sentence
which appeal is like okay there are
maybe if like cause
[Music]
i'm affected by the field
to some extent still
showing something to me some some
imbalances whatever and
for me the lower chakras things you know
the first second fair chakras
um themes
and yeah they're very present in the
collective actually that's most of the
most of the things that the collective
most people like
lines for like all day long and for
for many days in a row this
three first chakra stuff
so for me it cannot very powerfully
this dead stuff came so
strongly and sort of immediately after
this this time oh
cool hello hello hello
hello
old friend you know and and here i have
this like
still like some portions of that
to to clear to
transmute
[Music]
that's a good point it's a really good
point
yeah society
the friction being projected
[Music]
let's see if gillard comes back that's
that's a good point
drop the mic leave he's back okay
that's that's right for him it's pretty
interesting about
friction being projected as though
it both feels that way on the nervous
system but even that is still
a slide a frame
on the movie that we then add
meaning and symbolization to
saying that that it feels
that way that it feels the stickiness it
feels that way that that's energetically
how it feels we're describing we're
adding descriptors
versus it being completely absence of
symbolization and
absence of descriptors like it literally
just
is
the whole that is this and this is that
just came to mind yeah
he lost him oh there he is get a little
switcheroo then
i was like oh he came in on another
device
the whole the whole idea of
this being the absolute
is mind-blowing
that in itself is enough to just get
somebody to
just melt
[Laughter]
[Music]
and that's when you can't describe
that whole phenomena that gilad
mentioned
then there's no description because it
just is
it's just perfect
and that then there's all the
descriptions oh
my nervous system feels more sticky when
it's around the matrix
versus my nervous system feels a lot
more harmonic and warm warm warm when
i'm around
six density and like yeah then there's
all the descriptors
yeah that's what's called saguna brahman
versus nirguna brahman
nirguna is when you don't have any
descriptors around the absolute
and saguna is when you begin describing
it and you begin saying well
actually the absolute is structured this
way and like it appears this way and
blah blah blah
yeah it's a classic debate that's been
had
in which it's both it's always
simultaneous but
it's been had for yeah a thousand years
more
that's a good point gillard i like that
one the stickiness is inside you
so meaning that if you feel stickiness
then
check your where yourself check your
consciousness
it's pretty interesting it's all it's
all just here yeah
yeah the stickiness can be the but to
who to who that's that's it
[Music]
as within soul without that's such a
good
one i love that one yep
so yeah so as soon as you feel something
like that and you begin describing or
symbolizing the stickiness
then recognize that that's a mirror of
what's happening internally
yeah it's great it's really instantly
bringing the unconscious to conscious
like like thank you thank you for that
like
um
[Laughter]
it's almost like why are you not okay
accepting what's happening right now
it's almost like what it's saying uh but
at the same time
there's like you can be okay with
accepting the cloud
but then you also are wise in the sense
of
seeing the possibility trajectory
and saying that i don't actually
i'm not i'm using will and choice to not
pursue this this fourth one and i'm only
going to leave this
highest one available that's the one
that i'm
shifted into permanent alignment with
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
um
this new energy baseline i've been
it really has been like a permanent
shift and i was telling
i think gina earlier like now that i
know when i'm not feeling that
vibrational alignment within it's a
choice to not feel that
and there's something in my
stickiness of not feeling that that i
have to
just become aware of to shift instantly
and i'll never forget when we were
sitting there
and you were like that's your natural
state it was like
why do we complicate it so much like
natural yep
that's why rumi said that between all of
the words we say
so much love is lost
love is awareness love is being
fundamentally pure raw uncolored
unsymbolized undescribed
just the very fact that there is an
observer
in the reality itself is enough
for you to recognize that that's your
true nature
the endless witnessing
the endless observing eternal
observation
eternal intelligent infinity immersing
itself
as an impersonal awareness
into creations endlessly coloring itself
with form
look at all these cool little cute
costumes here these four
cute costumes we have hillary we have
gina with
atlas we have these cute-ass costumes
and they have all this little cute
identity and form
but what's underneath of all of that
what is the
same and immovable underneath of all of
it
the very fact that we are aware
underneath of the costumes
that is your nature that awareness that
is endlessly going to be wearing
costumes forever
forever forever ever forever ever
wearing
costumes
that which makes endless costumes
that which is beyond all costumes
[Music]
the costumes are fun so fun
we'll play we get the dress i've been
playing
but remember to focus on the eternal
stage
rather than the play and the costumes
and you can and that's the simultaneity
is you can do
both but most people don't know there's
an eternal stage
most people only know the costumes in
the play and they don't even know it's a
play
they just see costumes they don't even
know it's costumes they think this is it
then they figure out there's costumes
then they figure out that it's a little
of the divine play and then they figure
out that there's actually an eternal
stage
which is endless having endless plays
and endless costumes
it just takes so much of the pressure
just
off like it just feels freeing like
liberating when you like say that and
put it like that you know
profound
that's that's so good we should we
should even recap it's so good
you you think we start by thinking
that we're a person that's finite and
separate
we think start there not always if
you're
born in the indigenous tradition you
might
grow up knowing your infinity in some of
those traditions
but you move in a sense from that egoic
separate personhood to recognizing that
you're wearing a costume
and then you go from knowing that okay
i'm just wearing a costume i'm awareness
wearing a costume
and then you go to holy [ __ ] this is all
a divine play called lila
this is all that a divine play
and then you realize that i am the
eternal stage i am that which makes the
eternal stage
and the endless plays and i'm wearing
this costume all at the same time
it's so good it's like the video game
analogy it's very similar to the video
game analogy
you think you're a separate person
in a game and then
you realize that you are
actually a in a video game you realize
you're in a video game
and then you realize that the video game
is is having the same awareness that is
impersonal
that is being played in the gina in the
gilad and the hillary characters
and then you realize that you are that
you are that awareness that's impersonal
and shared in the video game
and then you realize that you're the
[ __ ] creator of the game that makes
endless
games that then immerses itself as these
characters
in the video games that then goes around
and plays
all the different stuff in the game and
that
gains that unique experience and that
then
turns that in at the seventh density
going into the eighth into the next
creation
endlessly so yeah it's just the same
analogy
of the eternal stage versus the eternal
video game
yeah yeah
video game dream
i love the dream one too yeah you
literally can't
have a dream without an observer
i i don't i don't get it i don't get how
people don't get the salience of the
observer
if somebody told me this six years ago i
probably would have gotten it but nobody
quite said it this way
but like yo you can't have a dream
unless you immerse yourself into the
dream as an observer
of the dream and i would have been like
oh you know i would have gotten it a
little bit more
that consciousness or awareness is so
[ __ ] fundamental
there would be nobody here to experience
the reality if there was no observer or
witness of the reality
yeah and let me go direct and more
expansion on that
so you know beyond all these concepts
there is this
for me what power it fits very well here
and
what's also honest
in what we call myself or your or
whoever watches it kind
and they understand
all of its existences powers
so to speak that appears programmed to
be
seen separate and different once i start
to convict myself that
there is only one power there's only one
existence and feel it
now now actually feel
how the existence here is the existence
ever
there may be different view
oh attention but this one fundamental
source
is and that's beyond the mind that's
beyond the concept
it's all one object is always
it's only one it's only one it's only
right all only one here
now these distinctions are good but i
i'd like to take it to the direct
okay
that's another way to go
[Laughter]
now we can't forget
i just plastered across the bottom in a
banner for the rest of the episode
is so good with that yeah
thank you for that
really starts to relax any of the
tension that you'd feel
from when you're saying a stickiness or
any
which are good on a relative level to to
feel and
use as catalyst and everything but yeah
absolutely just
going back again and again to that
recognition that there's just one
it's just you
just
huh
steering wheel lock
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh my god
[Laughter]
oh
wow oh so good
how do you even articulate beyond that
realization
like the one the oneness we're
all one and then it just drops all
borders it drops all
resistance all limitations
it's all perception
i think we visualize it we do
directly experience it and then catalyze
other people directly experiencing it
and then that leapfrogs people up from
a third to fourth density and we
visualize it by
visualizing our true
infinite fractaling and finding nature
just like a heartbeat it's just like a
you go
out you have a lub and a dub
like a like a lub and a dub lub
dub systolic diastolic 120 over 80
120 over 80. right and that's like the
fractaling and finding
you know you go fractal outward
to like the parable of the prodigal son
where you have this like separation and
ego infinity and all these things and
then you
turn inward you stop trying to find
happiness in maya
and you turn inward and that's the
dub that's when you go inward to your
source
and then you become source full and then
you can firework
outward with love and service to other
and wisdom and unity and not
trying to extract from
experiences and people and substances
peace and happiness which is your true
nature yeah it's just
that that seems to be something really
important is the visualization
of the true nature because
it helps with
it helps with the direct experience
because people get it
like when you look at a hummingbird
and the way that the hummingbird like
goes to the like here's the hummingbird
and it goes to the flower and it comes
to the flower and it sucks out the
nectar of the flower
right like it's the same thing with the
big bang like there's a big bang
and then like there's humans that like
suck out the nectar
of the big bang of the creation
and so visualizing it's important
because it it gives people
a macro level
understanding of their true nature that
they can start with
intellectualizing and then work their
way to direct experience of
themselves as infinity endlessly
expressing itself
yeah that's actually that's actually a
very
high and advanced form of meditation
will be
in some in some way of it neutralization
and pedantic method the data is the
the science of basically the origination
or one of the
fundamental sciences of non-duality of
the nature of the self the nature of
reality
a method called mididiyasana
mididyasana which is actually
contemplating
um upon a subtle
object or feeling
for example the sense or the idea of
infinity
or space or something like that
and then through this contemplation
through this visualization
if you will or
meditation you go beyond the concept the
concept is perfect it's not a concept
infinity or like oneness or like
whatever is good for you
because it's similar in vibration to the
essence so the
visualization concentration
contemplation
upon the subtle concepts or images can
take you beyond
intensity with the proportion can take
you beyond the concept or the feeling of
the image
into realization or direct
so that's beautiful yeah that's a very
good point
it's a grief and highly common highly
recommended it can be applied
every moment of the day you don't have
to sit you don't have to do anything for
that
can you just like contemplate on on
infinity or on space or
on vastness or whatever you know for a
few seconds
for 30 seconds lunch
you know whenever any moment anyone you
can use this too you can use this
technique this tool and
and soak yourself in this expand
expansion
expensive vibrations and
remembrance yeah
different topic but something that came
up was
our callings and i don't think i've
heard yours
go on maybe we could share i think the
calling work is extremely powerful
to get really connected with your
unique essence of what your
what you came here to radiate
and i'm curious yeah what is your
calling
is
and maybe we'll give a little context
about this scoring work
in a few like one sentence
so the calling is like this
the signature vibration
of a being which represents
like the sort of the highest
so like the two essence of of one's
uh the highest
uh display to this
to this higher dimension to
intelligence to infinity so as as like a
sentence which is
others do it service to others with
effect of this vibration or this calling
in that in that way on others on other
people
what it means and then and then it
stands like the calling extends like a
ground or like a compa or
for being to to a life according to
this understanding of vibration or
[Music]
sentence my my calling is uh
people knowing they are
people knowing they are the source of
love even knowing that
they are the stars of love
powerful
hmm
you want to share your coding gina
[Music]
thanks for sharing yeah my calling is
people are inspired
[Music]
all right ask i can ask a quick question
before hillary and whatnot
gina
for me and i'm just curious this is a
reflection it will be interesting to see
how you feel about this
the way that
you know in a sense
there was a big level of contrast
energetically for me
between what was said between gilad and
you
and i am curious how you feel about this
there's almost this uh
you know people knowing they are the
source of love
and then there was sort of a
like a there's some sort of a
vibratory-esque like
source of love and then i don't know
what it was
maybe it was just the way that you you
spoke it maybe it was
i don't how aligned are you
energetically to people are inspired
i feel very aligned with it okay maybe
in that moment
i wasn't super aligned with it maybe
that's where you heard her
so tell me more about anything from
what does that look like people are
inspired how how
would that look like
pattern wise behavior-wise unleashed
unleashed yeah i would say it looked
like
an excitement a sort of like awakening
where i think i see visually
people going from a state of complacency
or more egoic
or yeah sort of that like
unpolarized just like
you're not service just so if you're not
service to others like you're just very
in the middle you're hanging out there
and then it feels like something
lights up in you or awakens and
there's an excitement to
realize yourself or to serve others
it could look like that yeah
cool does that yeah that helps a lot
that helps a lot
yeah yeah for me that helped a lot yeah
i i felt like you sharing the extra
couple sentences about it at least for
for me energetically in that moment in
this specific exchange
it basically took me to a place of like
okay holy crap there's so much more
behind this that you've really thought
about
and that really helped yeah yeah i love
that
great yeah
like a thing that uh richard said the
guy that we did the
calling work with that the the word
and the world are totally different
and so yeah i think
the words don't always convey that
and and maybe it's not just the words
but it's also
the the energetic expression behind
the word because just play play for a
second
my calling is people are inspired
my calling is people are inspired
you just want me to say it with more um
it's it's up to you you know you get you
uh but it's just there's a there's an
interesting juxtaposition
in terms of that's another good point
just to cross people's callings in
general
is that is just the energy level behind
it
like today on the actually i can't say
this but
in the no limit society group there was
a
specific instance of somebody sharing
their calling
from a place that was energetically like
you could tell that that wasn't
necessarily that final expression of it
and the person very clearly was like
yeah yeah it's not the final expression
of the blah blah blah
type thing and so that's also
interesting that we can sort of help
we're helping each other with that
process which is cool
yeah yeah yeah but that you unpacked
that really well that was helpful
hilary what's yours again yeah well gina
actually
helped me as well because mine was very
wordy
at first so i like i kind of broke it
down a little my first calling that i
like came up with
was people remembering their divine
infinity
through unconditional love and
it felt like the simpler the better like
that was a lot to unpack
so now i changed it to
people experiencing divine love
and it's all inclusive right it's
literally all a remembrance
like when you feel that divine
unconditional no limitation
feeling of just like love that we all
are at our core
it can't help but remind you of the
divine infinity that we are as well
so i think the simpler the better so
people experiencing divine love
it's a lot of beautiful similarity with
people knowing they are the source of
love
also cool very
very aligned in sync
i'm going to do a little episode on this
with our audience and just
people playing with their callings
and i'll mention mine on that episode
but briefly
my calling is people experiencing truth
and i would even for those that are
watching right now
i would say that
one of the most profound activities
which gina mentioned
is that this idea of calling is to
recognize what is your north star what
is your transcendent
noble aim what is the reason why you
took
physical focus in this incarnation why
why what are you here to bring as a gift
as a firework into the collective
and that might be just anything from
like being a
good parent all the way up to
it might be providing a billion people
with clean water that don't have access
to it so
it it can be anything it and so
that's a practice that's also been
proved
by the psychological literature as well
where if you have some sort of a noble
aim
you can find any how as a said
so with a large enough will you can find
any
how you'll actualize that so
it's a really important activity and
we'll do a little video about it
soon on the on the channel so
yeah i love it because it's really
it feels like an aim in a way it also
just
feels it is just what you are it is just
your essence that you are
radiating it's just war it's your being
in a more true sense beyond your
personality beyond all these layers
and so it feels like a
it has been feeling to me like a
re-centering
it's like re-centering in my own natural
essence
[Music]
your calling is what you are it's just
obscured it was another quote from the
richard and bentino
session yeah yeah that's what you are
and so the physical manifestation of
that
could be so many things
but it's just what you are and so you
can bring it to every single
interaction every single thing that you
do every yeah
anything yeah it's beautiful
yeah it's the blue and the blue one
the blue in the blueprint
yeah like the blue of the blue point oh
like uh
you can see also the the paper that the
blueprint is uh
the most fundamental substance of the
the mind the
yeah the individuated expression
is the fingerprint
the calling is the fingerprint the
calling is the
the iris your unique iris
around your pupil the pupils that shared
impersonal observer and the iris as the
unique
firework of that form
so what is the unique iris what is the
unique fingerprint what is the unique
blue in the blueprint what is the unique
calling
[Music]
the more that your calling is aligned
with
global awakening or enlightenment
the more that you will feel
like you're perpetually working on
becoming more
purified around service to other people
whereas if you're
calling if what you put in that north
star location
has something to do with maya with the
illusion if you
put a car or a house or a relationship
into that position you will inevitably
suffer because that's not really your
calling
you just
have your attention on it but yeah it's
not it's never
a car is never gonna be your true
essence
as an individuated expression
i came into physical focus so that i
could
own a mustang you know or i could own a
ferrari or i could have a 400 000
house like that's why i came here so i
could own this house
i needed that as an experience
yeah that's funny it's a good one
let's rap i'm feeling that yeah
all right let's do it should we wrap
with the meditation
i would absolutely love that
all right let's do it
relax
sink back
into awareness
into being into presence
into the timeless perfection that we
already are
uh
the very formless i am
shared impersonal eternal
the first attribute of the absolute
awareness
and what happens when you make
even that attribute of
awareness an object
and transcend even that
what ineffability remains
oh
realize you are that
[Music]
okay
another way to say it
you are not the lover
awareness you are not the loving
unified field
energies and you are not the beloved
which is the appearances the the mind
the the light itself
you are the heart you are the heart
in the three of them
um
abide as that
abide abiding
bye bye
bye bye
[Music]
oh
wow
yeah thank you thank you
it's exciting
yeah i look forward to more of these
costa rica
2021 sessions
so we'll
keep doing these as they blossom and
thanks everyone for tuning in we love
you very much we're very grateful
thank you let us know how you feel
yeah let us know how you feel in the
comments below we'd love to hear from
you
yeah if the video brought you value give
it a like
share it with people that you know bring
value to subscribe if you haven't
we'll put some links in the bio below to
our fellow homies
you need to go and check out so
well that's all thanks for having us
yeah
another version of the now
okay all right okay
okay all right i'm gonna call you i'm
gonna call you guys a program after this
i want to miss you too much
okay